je sais pas si vous êtes comme moi sur
les réseaux mais moi tous les soirs
j'évite le vide je regarde 5 minutes 10
heures plus tard mes mains transpire et
j'ai les yeux qui brûlent j'ai rencontré
un tas d'amis que j'ai jamais jamais vu
pour de vrai mais à l'heure où on donne
tous notre avis surtout aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est vrai
salut Tik Tok avec Keen'V on va se faire
le test de confiance parce que ça fait
combien de temps qu'on a mis
tu sais ce que c'est le test de
confiance j'imagine que c'est juste
devoir me balancer tu vas me manquer le
test de confiance et tu fermes les yeux
je laisse aller en arrière et si tu as
confiance en moi je te rattrape si tu
n'as pas confiance en moi tu ne te
laisses pas aller et si tu as confiance
en moi et que je suis un [ __ ] te
rattrape pas tu cours donc très vite
la confiance en moi je ne sais plus
non non non non
je fais rien
je suis là pendant les vacances je fais
rien on me propose de faire des
activités mais moi je ne fais rien
pendant les vacances
[Musique]
voilà pourquoi j'aime le monde rural là
je suis à Sauvigny en Champagne regardez
la générosité le partage tu rentres à
l'autre à l'entrée du village et là il y
a une boîte euh frais servez-vous la
générosité le partage tu prends tu
arrives ici on donne des œufs bon là ils
ont déjà été pris mais bon voilà